نبدا مساء العربيه بهذا الخبر المليء
باجواء رمضانيه فريده عاده ثانويه تتكرر
في منتصف شهر رمضان نظمت هذا العام افطارا
جماعيا ل 4000 شخص في منطقه المطريه الشرق
القاهره لتتحول المنطقه لمزار سياحي شباب
المنطقه الذين خلقوا حاله خاصه وهويه
لمنطقتهم على مدار تسع سنوات قاموا بتنظيم
افطار جماعي الالاف من سكان المنطقه
وضيوفهم بداوا بعشرين شابا قرروا الافطار
سويا وصل اليوم الى قرابه الارض 4000 شخص
يقضون وقتا ممتعا استطاعوا جذب انظار
الاعلام والمدولين وايضا سائحين
والدبلوماسيين اليهم ومنهم سفير كوريا
الجنوبيه الذي حل ضيفا على مائده المطريه
لهذا العام
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات